[Music]
so it's lunch time in New York City I'm
craving a slice of pizza I just heard
about this place and Yonkers it serves a
2-foot slice it is $10 there's only one
person I know that loves pizza more than
me so I'm gonna ask him to grab lunch
with me so uh did you want very much so
this is a two-foot slice of pizza for
ten bucks I've crushed more than one
Domino's in a sitting so it isn't like a
sanction to challenge I don't think is I
think they just sell we get our picture
on the wall you know I think no I think
a lot of people would not be the first
people to finish describe the pizza barn
so far I imagine more of a barn
[Music]
with natural size
so I've been it's I think the the pits
on the outside just eat the cake just
get help I urge going into this I was
like completely confident that I could
even survive that's big kind of normal
size like it does nice didn't box it
completely paint clear beyond what
generally is like there's no possible
way that me yes I don't know but I want
to stay I'm gonna stay positive I got at
first I'm thinking like fork-and-knife
is but is the only way you could eat
this but throughout point that's not on
your feeds in New York slice I think I
think I owe it to myself to do the fold
I need some support in the middle we're
in business you're racing grabbing
I see what you got going to meet you
really good retail cost is great I'm
working from around the side yeah then
I'm coming back through so I'm sort of
put it off the perimeter
how many slices do you think it is
five or six arrows it was a 5/5 or six
I'll make away I mean I feel I feel
confident here and that that amount of
grease though that's not appetizing
where is it
[Music]
you never know he's gonna do it
quadruples oh this one's double fault
he's an animal we do to account fixed
and he still has two as far as the rules
my motor functions are slowing when
proud of my my dent but I don't think I
can I don't think I can go up all right
well if you're bowing out athletes or
both of us cause you're trying so a
friend does look at that you really went
to town there is no room left I am a
morrow timeless last bite
[Music]
not too many people informational maybe
how to say the job tell ten people I bet
you super slice it's like that it may
still get the best of you
it's never launched together I'm so glad
you called
[Music]
wait
[Music]